join two of the greatest minds if the  Industrial Revolution Charles Dickens  the greatest novelist of the era should  you ever be in the mood for the tailor  to even always find me where the Ale is  warm and tempers are hot Charles Darwin  the scientists behind the theory of  evolution I am used to people  challenging my ideas in fact I live for  it will you join us yes help them in  their epic journey have your first case  people even ghosts the spirits that  haunt us are simply our deepest fears a  highly toxic plant has been found I fear  the good people of London might be in  danger not every problem can be solved  by blowing things sky high was the fun  in that every mission will unfold a new  chapter of their history because of  their legend is you right  pre-order Assassin's Creed syndicate to  continue their stories with even more  missions available friday october 23rd  you